[Music]
this one comes from shirley van vict
shirley what
shirley van vict it's the last name is
v-i-c-h-t
pastor skeet
i am taking my granddaughter to hike on
the sabbath to teach her about god's
creation
during the week we are at our different
schools as i'm a principal of an
educator
is this wrong
it's not wrong sabbath is a good time to
tell your children about god as creator
but all during the week is a good time
to tell them that are you following me
i haven't distressed creation a lot when
they serve the sabbath and there's
nothing wrong with that but the high
point of creation was not trees
the high point of creation wasn't
flowers it was the creation of adam and
eve are you following me because trees
were not made in god's image flowers
were not made the sea was not made the
fish was not made in this image only
adam and eve consequently the high point
should be are we
how can i be more like my creator he
made me to be like him a tree doesn't
have to be christ-like the river doesn't
have to be christ's life yes god made
the tree i'm not against that but we
need to focus on what about me
i was made in god's image let me forget
the tree for a minute what about me
am i living life christ wants me to live
am i reflecting his image and that can
be taught a little child yes talk about
the tree but let your your statements
center on
god wants you to be like him in your
little way
to going to make that tree whatever i
want you to be like him because the high
point of creation was the creation of
humanity not the creation of trees but
god bless all trees don't misunderstand
me i love trees i'm looking at trees
right now out of my window i love the
water i know fish i love animals that
are birds i love birds
i wish i could fly but the high point of
creation was the creation of people
they were made in his image
not not not trees and birds i like them
but christ didn't come to die for bird
he came to die for me
and so the high point of sabbath
observance should be father am i being
what you created me to be
i'm not ignoring creation physically no
there are lessons to be learned the
heavenly declare the glory of god the
earth is full of his glory but
the focal point of creation was the
creation of individuals that they may
reflect on
amen amen thank you so much i'll escape
god bless sister van victor little girl
i mean that little girl grow up to
reflect christ and have a place in
christ kingdom when he comes
and all of the little children listening
to this program
and god bless all the parents with
wisdom to raise them we are living in
difficult times
what a time to raise children
amen amen indeed you know there's just
so much corruption in media
and it's just right at the fingertips of
our of our youth that's right that's
right
you